CEL sword pretty much sums it up a poor
man has a sword a rich man needs a man
with a sword goal is exchanged if the
poor man knows how to use this sword
maybe he becomes the rich man one way or
another I'm sure sell swords have a long
and illustrious history but if you meet
a sell sword who knows it best is
someone else a sell sword should be good
at one thing getting paid to kill people
it's not an easy job most people try to
kill you back and at least a few of them
know how the ones that don't well they
often common and off pretty armor to
ruin an afternoon a lot of high lords
turn their noses up at sell sorts
let's say they can't trust a man who
sells his allegiance to the ice bidder I
don't blame him much cheaper for them to
own an army from birth either by people
being on their lands or by their
ancestors swearing a few oaths but
here's the thing no sell sword has ever
fled from the winning side if you're
hired companies are running away from
you it's because you're not on that side
and you didn't pay him enough to die
with you know that you could sell swords
don't get rich dying for their Lords
sell swords don't really get rich some
of the Eastern companies on their souls
still fine the golden company the second
son the wind blonde [ __ ] a bit of
fighting to be had in the Free Cities
even if those merchant princes can be as
tight as an old man's [ __ ] but then
you're stuck in the heat and dust hoping
some dumb rich prick doesn't try to hire
company to fight death rocky because you
don't really captain would probably take
it
hedge Knights now are a different breed
take a sell sword and remove the sense
they get their name from where they
sleep under the edges of the Seven
Kingdoms and ditches in stables they
don't have the family name or the purse
like real Knights so they spend all
their money on armor and a horse and
ride in Tony after Tony in the open
impressing some Lord or winning some
prize one loss and a lot of them are
ruined they can't ransom back their
armor even if they win think what a
knight's good for killing men you know
how you train for killing men by trying
to kill men not prancing around with a
blunted stick bowing and waiting your
turn
maybe you think I'm just insulting the
competition so you hire me instead well
of course I am so don't hire me I had a
cell sort with educated heirs who tells
you all about the great battles he's
heard of or a hedge knight who was one a
few tourneys starting to build his name
and the man you fighting against he
hires me